Oh today's questions another one about
man steel to a degree the glorification
of might is an issue that is baked into
the superhero narrative it's not
unavoidable but it is very much the
default because app core superhero
movies are about characters who are
Dietetic Lee more than ordinary they are
exceptional in inaccessible ways that
set them apart from the reader or viewer
no matter how many times you cut
spider-man together with the baking soda
of great power great responsibility and
Mary Jane getting kidnapped at the end
of the day he's still spider-man now
there's nothing intrinsically wrong with
idealization fantasy ideals help us
contextualize ourselves and who we want
to be but a work that gets caught up in
that a medium that gets caught up in
that risks losing track of the grounding
elements that make ideals relevant and
not merely pornographic wanker II as an
example of how this can work let's go
back to spider-man just in case it seems
like we're beating up on the kid a
little too much many of the writers have
attempted to use his exceptional nature
as a fable of sorts painting a world
where being special doesn't solve all of
your problems which turns a subtle
critical lens on the core power fantasy
Sam Raimi spider-man 2 is a great
example of this as Peter still needs to
work and eat and sleep and go to class
but as a counterpoint to the exact same
argument spider-man's moral with great
power comes great responsibility
can just as well be seen as buying into
the broader superhero narrative of might
as right to rule where the natural order
is for the exceptional or those with
great power to take care of all of the
problems because the masses are
incompetent or power less see there's a
really fine line between the strong
should care for the weak and the strong
should rule the weak and superheroes add
an extra dimension by drawing a really
obvious line between the strong and the
weak if you have superpowers
you are strong if you do not you are
weak this takes on a disturbing element
when you consider how many superheroes
have a superpower that essentially
amounts to opulent wealth or a wealthy
benefactor Batman
man iron man green arrow iron fist and
how many real people believe that wealth
is strength and strength is the right to
rule so thanks it's a great question I
love to talk about the ethics and
morality of superheroes it's nice
because they're fake no one really has
laser vision so it's a disarmed slightly
distant sort of way to discuss real
world problems power how we relate to it
in a broad metaphorical sense and that's
the strength of stories and you can let
me know what you think in the comments
and as always if you've got a question
you could submit it through ask fm or
contact me on Twitter now go in peace my
children in the name of like share and
subscribe
amen